we don't usually focus on $100 video
cards it just doesn't seem to be what
you guys want I mean seriously in the
last year of graphics card launches our
most successful video covering them is
lonus being all like holy to a $5,000
cuadro m6 th000 and our second most
popular is the launch review of the 1080
a card most viewers can't afford not
knocking you guys it's just really
expensive and not a great value compared
to its little brother the bottom line is
that it seems like the internet would
rather watch us react to a Lamborghini
than give a square level-headed review
of a Civic but that won't stop us and
we're back at it again with a review of
the rx460 a video card designed for
mainstream and Esports games at 1080P
and aimed squarely at the1 100ish dollar
price point the sort of I guess I'll
need to address the absolute mess that
is graphics card pricing these days
[Music]
cooler Masters master case maker 5
features their free form modular system
allowing you to customize adjust and
upgrade make it yours at the link in the
video
description let's begin with the look at
graphics card pricing that I promised
the current AMD RX product stack
officially goes from 99 for a 2 gig
rx460 all the way up in pretty well
spaced increments to 23 $39 for the 8
gig rx480 but this is all according to
the suggested price list that they give
to us when we're sent a card for review
which is the only pricing reference we
have when making a video for a card
before its release so in our launch
reviews when you see a price to
Performance comparison these are the
numbers we're using they're official
they're supposed to represent the
Baseline price for this GPU and they
should be correct fortunately we're a
bit late on this car and it's already
available in stores which gives us the
opportunity to ask why the when looking
at newegg.com is there only one single
card in amd's entire RX product stack
that is at MSRP a reference RX 48 8 gig
and I'm not just going after AMD about
this NVIDIA GTX 1080 no cards on NewEgg
at 599 GTX 1070 no cards at 379 from any
brand I'm just mad about it because some
people make purchasing decisions based
off priced performance graphs it makes
sense and we make some of those graphs
based on the numbers that they give us
which has resulted in them being
unintentionally misleading this isn't
good for me then it's especially not
good for you but enough about that let's
dig into Polaris 11 in its desktop
flavor the rx460 it's a fourth
generation gcn architecture chip on
global foundry's 14 nanometer finfet
process it's got 14 compute units and
896 stream processors with reference
boards running at a boost speed of 1200
MHz and a memory speed of 7 gbits per
second with a Peak Performance of 2.2
Tera flops less than half of the rx470
but still a lot better than the 100ish
dollar cards we've seen in the past it
comes with two or 4 gigs of gddr5 RAM
depending on the variant you purchase
with a rated total memory bandwidth of
112 GB per second on a 128bit interface
the suggested ports are one display port
1.4 connector one HDMI 2.0b connector
and one DVID connector a fairly future
proof Loadout and typical board power is
below 75 Watts meaning that like the
Beloved 750ti a great upgrade card at
the time for folks with pre-built
systems it doesn't need an extra
connection from the power supply and can
daintly sip on it 75 watts of power
through the motherboard which brings us
to the specific variant we have today
the XFX Double dissipation 4 GB Radeon
rx460 with a metal card extender and
added pcie power six pin connector two
large fans and a whopping 20 MHz Factory
overclock it also features easily
removable fan Clips but not easily
removable fans confused so was I XFX has
a technology called hard swap detachable
fans which features these same clips and
fans that connect by touching contact
points instead of being directly wired
in a really great feature which looks
the same on the outside as this one but
when you remove these these fans they
just kind of dangle there cool I guess
but not as cool but when's the last time
you thought to yourself gee I sure wish
I could hot swap my computer fans
anyways let's talk about benchmarks in
directx11 with Crisis 3 and Rise of the
Tomb Raider it Trails the r9270 and the
GTX 950 but does unsurprisingly wreck
the 750 Ti moving up to dx12 however we
see a bit of a different story it edges
much closer in Tomb range and actually
beats all but the gtx950 in ashes of the
singularity and you can check out my
dx12 and Vulcan video here to learn more
about why moving on we have some new
additions to our test lineup that I
specifically included because of the
positioning of this card Dota 2
Counter-Strike GO and OverWatch all of
these are mainstream games and
relatively easy to run but because there
is a highly competitive component
serious players are still willing to buy
a dedicated video cards they don't see
any dips or stutters in the game and the
most interesting story here isn't
necessarily where this card slots
against others in the list it's more the
fact that it's theoretically anyways a
very lowcost option which manages to
play all three of these games at near
100 FPS or above with medium to high
settings that makes the rx460 a great
choice if those are the kind of games
that you really want to play and based
on the kinds of views that our value AMD
builds from 2 years ago have that's
probably a lot of people but the
conclusion of this video isn't that
simple because this card costs
$150 only 30 less than the MSRP for the
ARX 470 a much faster card making it
much harder to recommend not that those
cards are actually available at MSRP
anyways Mass drop in a nutshell they
take eager buyers lots of them and eager
companies with products to sell and they
connect them and the idea is that the
more people agree to buy the product the
lower the price goes that is to say to a
limit unfortunately you will not be able
to get the red scarf 2 custom keyboard
that we're covering today for $0 but you
will definitely be able to get a better
deal on it so this is the virgin
virgin this is the version C of the Red
Scarf 2 it is designed without the 10
function keys of its predecessor and
features a unique 68 key layout it
consists of a PCB and a CNC aluminum
case plate and feet and allows for
customization of the lighting layout
including ISO and ansy it's fully
programmable allowing the user to
utilize the unique layout as they see
fit and there are a variety of choices
of anodized aluminum colors it comes in
black gray red or silver you can also
add a set of standard layout blank or
laser etched front printed PBT key caps
in cherry profile and the lighting can
be controlled via a remote so to check
out this one and other drops check out
that link in the video description Mast
drop has all kinds of great stuff
everything from keyboards to camping
gear so you can be a keyboard Warrior or
a weekend
warrior anyways guys thanks for watching
if you lik the video like it if you
disliked it dislike it get subscribed
all that fun stuff if you want to buy a
card that probably isn't this one check
out the Amazon link the video
description down below you can also see
the link to buy our shirts down there
those are those are cool if you want to
discuss the value propositions of
different cards and maybe the pricing in
your area we can't talk about the
pricing in every different country here
but I know there's crazy stuff going on
all around the world not just in the
states and we're even Canadians and
there's crazy stuff going up here too so
yeah let us know on the Forum and I'll
see you guys next time watch this video
which is our review of the rx470 a
probably more sensible card to buy